Hi, my name is
Lisa Wray, and I'm
a Developer Advocate at Google.
Today I'll show you how
to implement sliding tabs
like the ones you may have
seen in the Google Play Store.
This is what we'll end up with.
You can see the Tab Indicator
move smoothly from tab to tab,
providing continuous touch
feedback as the user scrolls.
The first step is the layout.
You need two things,
Tabs on the top
and a ViewPager on the bottom.
Make sure to use the full
package name for the Sliding
Tab Layout because it's a Custom
View included in our project.
Next, we'll follow a specific
order to set them up.
Find your ViewPager and set
it's Adapter and then second,
set the ViewPager on
the Sliding Tab Layout.
The last thing to
do is to implement
the Adapter for your ViewPager.
You can do whatever
you want here,
just make sure to
override getPageTitle.
The ViewPager calls this
method in the Adapter
to get the title that's
shown for each tab.
Here, I'm generating it
based on item position.
Let's look at
another example where
each tab is a different color.
The tabs take care of blending
the colors together for you
as you transition from each tab.
As you can see, the
Messages Tab is red,
and the Photos Tab is
yellow, but the indicator,
when it's halfway
between them, is orange.
To start this example, first I'm
initializing some simple data
from my Pager.
This is just a list
of simple objects
to hold the String Title and
Indicator Color and its Divider
Color.
Next, I'll set up the Views.
This time I'm using a
Fragment State Pager Adapter.
But you can use any
adaptor you'd normally
use with a ViewPager.
Again, remember to
set the Adapter first
before you set the ViewPager
on the Sliding Tab Layout.
Now I'm going to set a Tab
Colorizer on the Sliding Tab
Layout.
It's going to use the Stored
Color in the list of items
I created and make that the
Indicator Color for the Tab.
It does the same thing
for the Divider Color.
The Divider Color
applies to the Divider
on the right side of the Tab.
In our example, the
dividers are all gray,
but they could even
be different colors
if you need a very
colorful Tab Layout.
Be sure to check out the Sliding
Tabs Basic and Sliding Tabs
Color Samples for the full
working code of these samples.
Which is linked
in the description
along with these slides.
Thanks for watching.